should never do that's actually good  celebration hello sport Bible I'm Gary  Lineker I'm alongside Rio Ferdinand Alan  Shearer of course you've been sending in  your football videos we're gonna rate  them so let's have a look shall we  Danny Jones that's actually rubbish what  advice would you give them back in well  this is kind of circus for me in  celebration sure David Michael Heath  draw reek rocky Ribeiro chino' glad to  know Tammy Ola  I would never do that  like that personal trainers on a pewter  Chris how do you how do you get  pneumonia pitch yeah he's premeditated  oh my gosh CUDA Chris OH  Oh Rudi völler produce is that actually  probably John I love seeing nothing  very good somewhat better than you this  some needs a woman it's on tour these  free kicks malarkey that's not real what  does these skill was during a game what  we want his skill skill ability not  makes a paste and